what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we are picking back up again
with Incredible Hulk stuff but because
of the fact that the last Incredible
Hulk video that we did in terms of any
real measure of a story was part of the
Ultimate Universe I feel like a little
bit of a refresher is an order for
people who are new to my channel or
people who were coming back and have
kind of forgotten where it was that we
had we had left off when it came to the
the main whole continuity so up until
this point we've basically covered three
stories we covered a planet Hulk and
World War Hulk which I consider that to
be just one cohesive story since one
leads directly into the other you could
really read Planet Hulk and World War
Hulk as a singular event and of itself
we also covered the first volume of Red
Hulk and then we covered scars son of
Hulk the origin of the Incredible Hulk
son now those three stories basically
all led to this particular moment with
Incredible Hulk number 600 and what's
effectively the pre Liu to follow hulks
and world war Hawks what of course
Planet Hulk and world war hulk did as it
showed us how angry Bruce Banner can get
but those stories basically ended or I
guess World War Hulk ended with Bruce
Banner being taken back to a shield
facility where he was being held as a
prisoner what scars son of Hulk also did
is it kind of came out of left field but
it basically told us in the moments
before the destruction of crown City on
Sekar that led to the deaths of the
incredible Hawks wife and and all of his
followers that his wife had basically
spat out their unborn child and then
kept that job protected it within a
basically a rocky cocoon using the old
power which allows those who wield it to
manipulate the planet of Sekar itself
kept Skaar protected and then that led
into his own story whereby he learned
about his father and he sought his
father out and then that story ended
with him basically being sent to earth
and so that allows him to come to the
stories right now which will pick up an
Incredible Hulk number 601 I think and
it's actually where scar fights his
father and the juggernaut it's actually
pretty badass is a pretty awesome story
but Red Hulk vol 1 the last piece of
this little puzzle red hope vol 1 it
came along and said okay after the
events of World War Hulk when banner had
been taken prisoner
I guess been held you know three miles
underground another Incredible Hulk
popped up another hope just showed up he
was red and no one knew who he was and
in fact even within the confines of the
story at this point right now we still
don't know who he is now in hindsight as
the reader we know because the story's
been out for eight years and it was
revealed something like six years ago
and so we know who the Red Hulk is but
within the confines of the story and I
kind of like to keep this key this
allure going for the people who are not
familiar with the
Mythos we didn't know what was going on
with it all we knew is that he showed up
he basically took Thor's hammer he
lifted Thor's hammer he was able to take
out Thor he took out she-hulk he took
out Iron Man shield I mean he just laid
waste to everybody he literally just
started pummeling through almost the
entirety of the superhero community but
at the end of that story at the end of
Red Hulk vol 1 Red Hulk it seemed to
have been defeated by Bruce Banner
but as banner was going away he was
suddenly shot in the back by dr. Samson
and then we didn't really know what
happened after that all we knew was that
dr. Samson seems to burn working against
the Hulk as a spy or something along
those lines
what this story does what Hulk number 6
Thunder does is it basically brings
those things back but it shows us a lot
of what's going on behind the scenes in
terms of how it was the Red Hulk came
into existence now because of the fact
that this is again continually being
written by Jeff flow he gives us a
refresher and basically all the stuff
that I'd pretty much just told you guys
what was going on but because of the
fact that Banner had been taken prisoner
people were just kind of curious as to
what was happening I mean Banner haven't
been taken away you know having been
shot by by doc Samson no one really knew
what was happening instead what we
actually end up doing is we pick up with
Ben Urich now Ben Urich is an extremely
important character in the realm of
Marvel Comics and this is actually
pretty significant considering the fact
that he's not a superhero Ben Urich sure
reporter those of you guys who remember
my videos on Civil War we basically
learned about bin Urich as a guy who was
operating behind the scenes essentially
chronicling the entirety of civil war
that's where frontline came in civil war
frontline was basically Ben Urich
sitting on the sidelines watching all
these events unfold in showing us how
civil war was impacting the average
person how it was impacting this
small-time superheroes with the main
civil war of in itself focus on you know
Tony Stark and it focus on Captain
America fighting each other and this
huge battle between the most popular
superheroes neo frontline showed us the
small-time superheroes and so because of
that because of the fact of Ben Urich
had been a huge part of Marvel Comics
even before civil war he's always been
there he's always been kind of the
behind-the-scenes showing us what's
going on but he's also the reporter that
everybody's learned to trust and Marvel
does that every once in a while Marvel
will take an ordinary citizen like night
nurse for example and they'll say here
is the one person everybody trusts when
they're superheroes that have masks and
they don't want people to know what
their identities are they go to night
nurse to be taken care of instead of
going to a traditional Hospital so that
way they don't have to worry about
losing their secret identities you know
a night nurse will work on them as she
needs to show heal their wounds and then
they'll go on their own way
they'll be superheroes again and so you
know Marvel does the same thing with Ben
here again he's just this reporter now
the trust that heroes have for Vinyard
comes into play when he's basically
called to a secret meeting by she-hulk
now she-hulk kind of refreshes Ben Urich
on what's going on but we also learned
that Ben Urich knows a lot of things
that he's not supposed to know for
example he knows about everything that
was going on behind the scenes with
world war hawk in the sense that Bruce
Banner had effectively been taken out by
satellites although it wasn't really
sure exactly how it happened more so
than that when it comes to the idea of
Red Hulk Ben Urich knows more than he
should a really good example of this is
when he's talking to she-hulk and he
says okay as far as I've been able to
tell or at least as far as as far as
I've been able to tell from all this you
know Red Hulk had essentially taken out
a bomber nation Red Hulk had infiltrated
that shield and the Baxter building you
know he's done all these things and and
she looks kind of astounded because you
know she repeats all of her back where
she's like that's all supposed to be
classified you know you're not supposed
to know any of that stuff and so what
she does is she says you're gonna come
with me you and I and a couple of the
people are gonna go on a mission and
we're basically gonna crack this wide
open we're gonna show what's going on
behind the scenes and we're gonna let
the world know what's happening now this
is a huge gambit for she-hulk because if
it backfires in her face she'll be
incarcerated should be thrown in jail
she'll go through a black bag over her
head and she'll never be seen or heard
from again and so it's one of these
really weird situations where she's
taking a huge risk not only that once we
arrive at this shield bunker that Bruce
Banner was supposed to have been held at
we find out that not only is doc Samson
here alongside Ben Urich but so is Peter
Parker now the reason why Peter Parker's
here is because she Hulk says you're
gonna need a photographer you're gonna
need somebody you can trust
if there's anyone out there that Ben
your trust it's spider-man and the
reason for this is because Ben Urich and
spider-man go back a long ways of Marvel
Comics they have a huge history I think
spider-man was actually the one that
convinced Ben Urich not to release the
identity of daredevil when he figured
out that daredevil was Matt Murdock it
was a huge deal you know but but the two
of them go back and forth because they
both work in the reporting field they're
both part of the Daily Bugle you know
they both report to Jay jonah Jameson
and Robbie Robertson I mean they have a
lot of similarities between the two but
because of the fact that he trusts Peter
Parker so much he's like look the Peter
Parker will keep our world hidden here
if it comes to the point that no one
needs to know that we were here no one
needs to know who it was to snap these
pictures Peter Parker will make sure
these pictures get to where they need to
go and no one will know who took them
none
we learn from from doc Samson that the
shield agents who were here are not
actually shield agents and that's the
first tip that Jeph Loeb gives us this
is not an actual shield bunker instead
this is a seems to be a bunker operated
independently by some third party
organization or nefarious group now
where doc Samson goes in and pulls out
some costumes that belong to aim to
advanced idea mechanics the various
scientists that are trying to take over
the world using technology and science
and what he also says is that these
shield agents are basically upgraded
life model decoys now I want to talk
about this for a second because agents
of shield the TV show which Jeff lobe is
currently you know running ended on the
idea of life model decoys this is
actually something kind of cool because
when I was watching the show I was like
life model decoys and they showed may
was actually a life model decoy when the
real May was being held prisoner what it
seems like Marvel's doing with a dose of
shield right now is they're taking the
road of Nick Fury versus shield where
life model decoys takeover shield and
Nick Fury along with maybe one or two
other people are able to bring them all
down that's the story that Marvel wrote
where Nick Fury stopped reporting to the
12 anonymous individuals and basically
made himself executive director and he
was the sole person in charge of shield
that's basically how that story unfolded
and while what comics is where that came
from but I kind of felt like it was
worth mentioning because life model
decoys are exactly where they sound like
they're literally life model decoys with
the exception of people who can somehow
tap into machinery like Tony Stark or
people like for to intuitively know how
machines work no one would know that
their life model decoys they look they
talk they act like real people they
sweat they spit I mean they they do all
the kinds of stuff that normal human
beings do and so it's impossible almost
impossible to know the difference
between a life model decoy and an actual
human not only that once we get in here
once we get into the shield facility we
actually learned that MODOK is running
the show now we've almost never talked
about MODOK and there's a reason for
that because MODOK is who he is a
villain that I don't really care too
much for just because I feel I feel like
he's really cliche but he's effectively
leading what's called the Intelligencia
now we'll get to that here in a minute
especially once we get into like world
war hawks and all that kind of stuff
because things get really really crazy
but in essence what doc Samson tells us
is that MODOK is trying to create a
gamma powered super soldier program
they're literally trying to make what
made Captain America great and they're
trying to make Incredible Hulk super
soldiers that's basically all they're
trying to do here now of course what doc
Samson also says is that he had
we've been brainwashed he had been used
by MODOK for the purpose of not only
leading them here but also feeding them
information in the efforts that once
they get here they would be easily
subdued now the funny thing about this
and maybe is something that I had missed
but once they once they break in once
dr. Samson shows up at this location and
starts tearing everything up when he
turns into his Hulk form ultimately you
know MODOK doesn't really seem to know
what's going on but the conflict here is
pretty straightforward because the idea
is that they want to even if they are
discovered even if they are seen the
goal is to get in get what they need and
get out before quote-unquote he arrives
now we don't learn who it is that
they're talking about until we have Ben
Urich as this last man kind of watched
these events unfold because remember
he's a normal guy he has no powers but
then suddenly he's met with the arrival
of the Red Hulk and that's really what
they were worried about because right
now there's no one that can stand
against the Red Hulk as it stands right
now in Marvel Comics in this story there
does not seem to be anyone who could
hold their own against Red Hawk Ares
couldn't do it Carol Danvers couldn't do
it she Hall couldn't do it Thor couldn't
do it no one can stand against him he's
taken every last one of them out now the
cool thing about this though is that
spider-man suddenly comes in now again
you know Peter Parker being here Ben
Urich didn't really seem to put the dots
together that Peter Parker is spider-man
but of course Peter Parker takes off
changes into his costume and begins
engaging in a fight with Red Hulk and
something that I'd like you to notice
here is this shows us how smart Peter
Parker is and his ability to fight foes
and then carry that experience over to
other phones what he does is he
basically starts running circles around
Red Hulk and the point that he makes is
yeah man like I've fought the Incredible
Hulk before and sure you're a little bit
different in terms of your physical
appearance and in terms of your powers
but at the end of the day you're a giant
lumbering Beast just like he was and you
can't hit what you can't catch and
that's that's that's exactly how he
plays it he's just like if you can't
catch me you can't hit me
so all I have to do was either wear you
out tire you out or I can simply just
ham you up and spider webbing and then
call it a day now the funny thing about
this though is that this is Red Hulk and
as intelligent as Peter Parker is the
Red Hulk is that much more strategic and
so because of the fact that this is
literally military intelligence going
against scientific intelligence at the
end of the day Parker just doesn't
really seem to be able to pull it off on
his own and so this is what we
officially get the return of Bruce
Banner in this instance whereby as he
watches Peter Parker being manhandled by
Red Hulk he suddenly emerges from his
tank and just begins attacking the Red
Hulk now under normal circumstances I
would have
listen said okay here we go again jet
flow its Red Hulk vs. Green Hulk and
yeah it's cool but it really it was a
one-hit wonder it was cool the first
time now it's wearing thin that's not
what he does he says hey on the surface
it looks that way on the surface it
looks like it's just always Red Hulk
fighting Green Hulk
that's not the case instead what Red
Hawk says is he has the ability to
absorb different forms of radiation and
the radiation that he chooses to absorb
here is the gamma radiation of Bruce
Banner effectively he strips Bruce
Banner at his ability to become the
Incredible Hulk now of course with the
Incredible Hulk we know this is not
permanent and in fact by the next issue
he'll be Incredible Hulk again but for
the time being it actually works out
pretty well now this is where I wanted
to kind of step in for a second and move
away from this quick little thing and
talk about some of Jeff Loubs other work
because when it came to Red Hulk we had
a couple other story arcs we basically
had red versus green or Hulk red green
and then we had I think it was called
Hulk no more it was kind of a weird
thing but basically it was it was
self-contained stories originally they
were in continuity in the sense that Joe
fix-it hulk came back you know he was
fighting against the century and Carol
Danvers and then eventually he turned
into the Incredible Hulk and then he was
fighting windigos it was really kind of
weird Red Hulk was fighting she-hulk and
the lady liberators so Valkyrie Susan
storm a rural Monroe Thundra he was
holding his own against them but then
what happened is Jeff lobe came back and
wrote a story where it was basically Red
Hulk becomes a Silver Surfer they were
all kind of fighting Galactus at the
behest of a conflict that was initiated
by the Grandmaster in the collector who
were elders of the universe and then
they wrecked hounded all the you know
when I say that you know now that I say
that I really feel like I need to do
videos on that like I'm gonna try that
video Red Hulk becomes the Silver Surfer
like that man
the views but no it was it was it was
kind of cool but the reason why I
skipped over that is because what Jeph
Loeb did is he came back at the end of
all that and he basically retcons all he
said okay none of that happened instead
it's Red Hulk vol 1 straight into the
Incredible Hulk number 600 and so that's
really kind of the reading order for
those of you guys who are trying to
figure out what to do with you with with
Red Hulk
it's literally Red Hulk vol 1 and then
the Incredible Hulk number 600 going
into fall of hoax and World War Hulk so
especially once we get to Hope pool Dead
Pool guys
Deadpool becomes a Hulk like I'm just
throwing it out there right now Deadpool
becomes a whole and now that story will
be told do not
I'm gonna tell that story but in the
midst of all this conflict and all this
this battling and so on the Red Hulk
seems to have no concern over the fact
that he's basically laying waste to this
facility not only that but because of
the fact that this facility is being
destroyed the way it is it's ultimately
leading to its own destruction and so
what ends up happening is in the last
few seconds or so we basically have a
bomb we have Rick Jones saving you know
Ben Urich and Peter Parker coming out
alive and ultimately it's it's just kind
of a scenario where things begin to wind
down and so what we end up doing is we
basically end up picking up with Ben
Urich and Ben Urich it suddenly met with
Red Hulk again now Red Hulk who you know
of course kind of take some few jabs
that here when Ben you're saying I can't
believe you lived everybody looks like
well yeah of course I lived like why why
would I why would I die in the explosion
of a building like I'm I'm red whole
gamut like I don't die and I will die
and when buildings blow up you know and
so what he does is he basically says you
know I'm under the impression that
you're writing a story I heard you're
writing a story about everything that
you saw and he says if you do that then
you'll be in a meeting one day and then
suddenly everybody's gonna die I'm gonna
bring that building crashing down and so
what he basically does is he tells us by
way of this story that is never going to
go into publication that it's much like
Watergate in the sense that it all
started like a basic break-in it was
nothing too big but then it spiraled out
of control and then ultimately MODOK had
basically activated you know advanced
idea mechanics they all began working
together that general Thunderbolt Ross
has committed treason against the US
government and shield although we don't
exactly know how and that they're
effectively starting a super-soldier
program using gamma radiation to create
their own variety of hawks and so again
what this did is it basically just kind
of lays the groundwork and says okay
here is the prelude quote-unquote to
follow up Hulk's and world war Hawks
here's how it is that all the
superheroes end up turning into hulks
here's this massive conflict descender
way when it's just Hulk vs. Hulk when
everybody is a hawk it's really kind of
weird but any event again you know this
is just kind of an introductory issue
this is saying the stage for things to
come but in the next video what we'll do
is we'll actually kind of wrap back
around will basically cover the story of
you know Bruce Banner Hulk versus a son
because it's really kind of weird as
that seems to run alongside follow-up
hooks of World War Hulk as best as I can
tell but what we'll do is we'll go ahead
and cover those stories and then we'll
jump into fall of Hulk's and World War
Hawks but if you guys are new here to
comics explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the
robb core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and leave a
comment down below let me know what you
guys think about Incredible Hulk stuff
so far because I'm actually really
interested to see what you all say
and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]